I'm back  you know that voice in your head one  that tells you right from wrong what  what happened guess what I found your  creeps on this time you know he has a  sleeping disorder the Bible it was  buried here with me you're here to keep  it safe him not it the whole worlds in  on the action  got knocked out by a girl rebel Wilson  is coming to television eight the  Edwards Broadway ten singles will do  ridiculous things for like a 91  everything a teenager good one Harry  Gannon is one tough mother D on the  field did you spend your time worrying  about the worst-case scenario and it  actually happens you've lived it twice  if you're gay then how did you and Mom  have sex  ah good luck with that see that plenty  of room  20 dollars what's this for well the next  time my son died 32 years ago hello  there well turning green and goes  million miles per hour frog in a blender  you